[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
two big developments in cases
surrounding the parkland high school
shooting
will the new state attorney take the
death penalty off the table
plus alleged sex cult leader keith
renire
wants to pick the prison where he'll
serve what looks like a life sentence
and sentencing hearings in two hate
crimes
one involves burned churches and a
sheriff deputy son
also voters pass criminal reform
measures in a number of states
we break down the changes a law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin let's begin
with legal development surrounding the
parkland florida high school shooting
a newly elected state attorney is taking
over as the top man
overseeing the case harold pryor won the
election
as the first new person to hold the
broward county prosecutor's office in 44
years
former state attorney michael setz is
retiring
prior a democrat beat better funded and
better known challengers by campaigning
heavily in neighborhoods
and churches pryor has said he opposes
the death penalty
which the former state attorney was
seeking in the parkland case
that brings us to a hearing in a civil
lawsuit filed by the parents of parkland
school shooting victims
nicholas cruz is accused of murdering 17
people and injuring 17 others
his criminal case is ongoing but so is
this civil suit which
accuses the district of failing to
identify and stop the threat
attorneys for the district want the
parents to hand over psychiatric
records to prove they suffered mental
anguish
some have no records to produce one
concern the plaintiffs have is whether
their medical records would become
public
and the school board seems willing to
help prevent that we got a good
qualified protective order that
hopefully
will serve the purpose that you know
some of the family was concerned their
medical records being out in the public
domain very understandable nobody wants
that
and that protection order keeps that
type of stuff
out of the court file uh it has a very
specific uh and this is all in new york
you know you signed this on october 14
2019
and it protects psychological records
school records medical records
and it gives some parameters as to how
we as lawyers go about all of us
both sides go about protecting that
information there is about five
parties that have identified that they
had
no treatment um so there are no records
to produce which is
understandable um and and that's where
we are then we have another
uh five again that we've not
heard from um
one way or another the school board is
seeking mental health records from the
plaintiffs which date from
before the parkland shooting one of the
attorneys representing the surviving
family said those records should remain
private this ancient concept
that the minute uh a party as a
plaintiff
in personal injury wrongful death post
traumatic stress
any types of claims like that any tort
claims
involving the the kinds of uh damages
that are asserted
this ancient concept that everything
becomes an open book
your life becomes an open book is simply
not true
and there's no good reason that
someone's personal
life is exposed because of claims that
they have legitimately
in my opinion any mental health
psychiatric
emotional records dealing with the with
the clients that i represent
on those claims post-incident
relating to the incident relating to the
cause of their
stress their disorders and things of
that nature clearly relevant
but there are matters that are contained
in some of the pre-records
that have nothing to do with um
what occurred on that horrible day
and their and their issues post
brian and terry here now so terry how
hard will it be for the families who
lost children to win a civil case
if they don't have mental health
treatments to back up their ptsd claims
it won't be that difficult aaron as a
matter of fact you can
have mental health issues and never
seek mental health treatment and so just
by
testifying as a witness and saying that
you had mental health issues should be
enough
obviously the more evidence the better
and obviously if you sought treatment
and if you have records and you produce
them fine
but i don't think it's necessary here
particularly because
their children were murdered and their
children were you know
shot down and this is an egregious crime
and every parent
obviously is going to have some mental
stress you shouldn't even have to
document that
it seems so obvious to everyone but the
school board is pushing for these
records
brian i've got to ask about the criminal
end of this because we've got the new
county attorney elected
in the 2020 election he's anti-death
penalty that's what his platform has
been but he hasn't from what i've read
commented directly on the parkland case
could he
take the death penalty off the table for
nicholas cruz after
the previous county attorney fought for
it
absolutely and he might even feel
emboldened by it because of the fact
that he was elected
on that platform it could be the people
asking that not only cases going forward
but cases that are currently going on
now should not have the death penalty i
think this is going to be something that
he needs to reach out to his
constituents
and maybe see what they want out of this
specific case yeah terry
this is just a fascinating development
in this case because this may change the
whole dynamic
absolutely i mean whether you have the
death penalty or not is really going to
depend on what the prosecution wants to
push forward and clearly it's a bigger
stake
case if the death penalty is on the
table and the proceeding has been
bumpy up until now because the death
penalty remains on the table
let's pause now to check in with chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
with what his team is working on this
week
thanks erin coming up this week on brian
ross investigates
allegations against a major u.s
healthcare company
that it ordered its salespeople to pose
as essential healthcare workers
and sneak into nursing homes offering
gifts of food to the staff
in order to sell its hospice services
they brought food donuts
gifts whatever they could
come up with to try and get themselves
in the door that's
this week on brian ross investigates
erin on the lawn crime trial network
thanks a lot brian and still ahead here
on law and crime daily the convicted
leader of a so-called sex
cult wants to pick the federal prison
where he will serve a 120-year sentence
but first voters in several states make
important changes to criminal laws we'll
have a breakdown
but law and crime daily continues in
just a moment
[Music]
welcome back everybody california voters
have rejected a ballot measure to do
away with some criminal justice reforms
proposition 20 failed by nearly 40
points in that state
it would have kept felons convicted of
some serious crimes from being released
earlier it would also have increased the
punishment for people convicted of
repeated retail
thefts and allowed for broader dna
collections former governor jerry brown
used his own campaign money to help
defeat proposition 20.
he supported criminal justice reforms in
2016.
a number of states passed new drug laws
on election day law on crime daily's
brian buckmeyer takes us through the
growing list of states to decriminalize
or legalize certain drugs brian thanks
erin
ballot measures are leading to big
changes here's the list
voters legalize recreational marijuana
in arizona montana
new jersey and south dakota medical
marijuana legislation was also passed
in south dakota and mississippi oregon
voters
voted to decriminalize the possession of
small amounts of drugs such as heroin
cocaine and lsd the decision is aimed at
moving people towards treatment
and away from jail cells but those drugs
are still illegal at the federal level
former federal prosecutor gene rossi
says he doesn't believe that feds will
actually mount a massive effort
to enforce their own drug laws the feds
are not going to go
near these cases because they got other
fish to fry i was a prosecutor
with the u.s attorney's office for over
20 years
and i learned this because i did a lot
of drug cases especially
oxy cases addiction is a disease
and mass incarceration is not to cure
and as someone who had cancer and almost
died
i know what the hell a cure is so this
is a great law
because it attacks the disease and not
necessarily the crime
these individuals who have these uh
addictions
they they can't control themselves and
to put them in prison
uh is just an incredibly uh irrational
thing to do
drug policy alliance executive director
cassandra frederick joins us specially
right now
on law and crime daily cassandra welcome
why are these measures in oregon so
important
this moment is a landmark because
oregon voters have told people that we
don't want to criminalize our loved ones
we want to give them access to health
care and harm reduction in housing
and so they've rejected the main
intervention that this country has
offered them which was criminalization
and really focused to divest those
resources from criminalization
and actually invested them into
resources
picking people and public health over
criminalization
so this focuses more on treatment in a
medical sense than on incarceration from
a punitive sense
cassandra i have to ask this as well do
you suspect the possibility of
increased federal enforcement or do you
agree with gene rossi one of our
analysts here
in saying that that's not likely
i think you know i've been asked this
question before about the federal
interventions and i think the thing that
i will say is that
oregonians chose this initiative by 58
and the focus is is that the overdose
crisis is actually rising in oregon
one in ten oregonians are struggling
with addiction
one in two oregonians are dying every
single day
what this measure does is that it
actually gets people the resources that
they need
and we're going to focus on that and if
the federal government wants to
intervene we're going to fight
because oregonians have made the choice
about what they need for their loved one
brian it's important from a legal
perspective to really look at the
details of what these laws actually do
yeah so for the most part these these
laws change especially in oregon when it
comes to the quote unquote hard drugs
it moves them from being a misdemeanor
or even felony
down to an e-level violation will it be
charged by with a hundred dollars
and be pushed in towards drug treatment
this is the
better choice drug laws are not working
over-criminalization of small amounts of
drugs has not worked
will not work and should be gone with
this is something i think that the rest
of the country should be looking at
and i hope that oregon succeeds with
flying colors so we can get on the right
track here it certainly sets up a model
potentially for other states to follow
terry if it goes
in a direction that other people agree
with what are your thoughts overall on
this
i couldn't agree more i mean we need to
look at the entire criminal justice
system
not only what we penalize people if they
are
found with small amounts of drugs on
their possession but
from the very beginning so that people
get this sort of help that they need
that they get the treatment that they
need that they're not
caught with any drugs in the very first
place so i think this
is a step in the right direction and i
think states need to take a look at what
oregon
is doing because it's a perfect example
of how we can
solve the problem versus just putting a
band-aid on the issue
and cassandra is your group moving
forward with trying this model in other
states
yes we are going all in on this we know
that drug possession arrests
are the number one arrests in the
country um
there is a drug arrest every 23 seconds
and we know that after a summer of so
much um
unrest when people were saying we need
our resources to go into things outside
of criminalization
there is an appetite here and so we
there this is invigorating
already ongoing efforts on the ground in
places like california and washington
and vermont
this summer drug policy alliance
published a federal framework towards
decriminalization
and we are having conversations in
congress the movement for black lives
and their breathe act will include all
drug decriminalization
and we're seeing you know even in covid
we saw
prosecutors say that they were going to
decline to prosecute drug possession
arrests because they didn't think it was
a good use of resources in the middle of
the health pandemic
so more people are talking about this
than people actually realize
it is a big conversation cassandra
frederick appreciate your time here on
law and crime daily
thank you and coming up next right here
on this broadcast sentencing for a
vermont
hate crime plus another sentencing for
the son of a louisiana deputy
this defendant burning historically
black churches
punishments in these cases are straight
ahead
[Music]
attorneys for the leader of the
so-called nexium sex call they're asking
for what some people might consider
special treatment in prison law and
crimes terry austin reports on that case
now
terry erin nexium founder keith renery
wants to be placed in protective custody
when he starts his
120 year prison sentence for sex
trafficking
in a letter to the judge renery's lawyer
cited
the media attention the case has
received and the nature of the crimes
they asked that he placed in a federal
prison
in pennsylvania that has a quote
sensitive
needs unit reneri claimed to be a
self-help expert
but prosecutors said he ran a sex slave
cult
where he branded women and forced them
to sleep with him
rainier's lawyers want him placed in a
prison that's within an
eight-hour drive of new york city as
they work on his appeal
thanks a lot terry a vermont man is
sentenced to time served for threatening
to set fire to a member of a hispanic
family
and exposing himself to them stewart
kurt rollins of berry pleaded guilty to
a federal hate crime charge
last july rollins harassed his neighbors
including two children
shouting racial slurs and telling them
to go back to mexico in his words
rollins also admitted to exposing his
genitals and his rear end to the family
and smashing their mailbox he's been in
prison for nearly a year and will
be supervised for three more years the
son of a louisiana deputy has been
sentenced for
setting three black churches on fire in
what authorities called an arson rampage
22 year old holden matthews pleaded
guilty to federal arson and hate crime
charges prosecutors say matthews
admitted to setting the fires and
posting photos of his work on social
media
he was sentenced to 25 years in jail
after a two-day hearing during
where some parishioners asked for a
harsher punishment
the case gained national attention last
year when politicians traveled to see
the aftermath
nobody should ever fear for safety in
their house of worship or
fear that their church will be destroyed
i don't know what this young man's
motive was
i don't know what was in his heart but i
can say
it cannot be justified or rationalized
these were evil acts but let me be clear
about this
hate is not a louisiana value
and violence has no place in our
communities we are better than this
yes and this is a reflection of one
depraved individual
it is not a reflection on the state of
louisiana
can a quote from baseball great yogi
berra help prosecutors win a murder
conviction
against a former pro baseball player on
crime daily returns with that case in
just a moment
[Music]
now to closing arguments in the trial of
a pro baseball player accused of using a
bat engraved with his
own name to murder three people
prosecutors say brandon willie martin
slugged his father his uncle and a
security systems installer to death
martin is facing the death penalty the
defense is raising mental health issues
but
is not arguing an official insanity
defense in this stage of the trial
however the defense provided hints for a
potential second stage which
could end with a death sentence
it's almost as if he is lost and i don't
mean lost geographically i mean lost
mentally it's almost as if he is
confused it's almost as if he's torn is
that
what do i do i'll pull over and
oh maybe i'll go i'm not going to go
fast
and then most importantly on this issue
do me a favor
listen to brandon's statement again and
when you listen to it ask yourself
am i listening to the reasoning and the
logic
and the inflection of a 22 year old man
remind listening to
an eight ten-year-old child detective
godfrey asks
who does the keys belong to what he said
she asks what do you enjoy he said i
enjoy
every aspect of life like what
eating dinner when asked is there
anything else
he said i enjoy not being alone ladies
and gentlemen
are these the statements of someone
capable of a cold
calculated decision when
confronted with why he was in custody
brandon said well
i ran from the police yeah but you know
you're here for murder
what murder against listen
to the words listen to the inflection in
his voice
he was as surprised as anybody to hear
that
prosecutors rebutted the defense's
arguments by quoting baseball hall of
famer yogi berra
he said too coincidental to be a
coincidence
that unknown person did all of this
while mr martin
is asleep in the front yard
that unknown person somehow leaves the
residence
and does not commit any other random
killings that day
too coincidental to be a coincidence mr
martin was able to make the decision to
run
a red light and to endanger
the community the citizens of corona
a near collision and four pit maneuvers
later
when he's finally crashed into and
disabled
that his vehicle disabled he gets out
and what does he do he flees
these are all conscious deliberate
decisions
he makes so we know
he can do that we know that this ball
player that can sign an 860 000
contract can make these decisions just
fine
so that was the rebuttal and we had a
verdict in this stage of the trial not
too long before broadcast time it's
guilty across the board here terry so
not quite a full home run for the
prosecution though because of course we
have the second stage of the trial
coming up now
well that's true but i think it was
somewhat less than a home run but
i think it was a home run seven counts
and he was found guilty on all of those
three murder
auto theft evading arrest obstruction of
the police officer
and finally injuring the canine so i
think the jury bought it you know hook
line and sinker
and in fact it was i think the right
verdict here because the evidence
really pointed to all of these charges
and a conviction
is i think as good as you can get even
though we don't know what the exact
sentence is going to be
so brian is there anything else the
defense could have done or should have
done
in this first stage of this trial i
don't really think so and and
to use the baseball analogy i'm not
quite sure it's a home run i would say
it's more like an rbi
someone was on third they hit a ground
single and that person came home because
there wasn't really much for the
prosecution to fight here
everyone kind of admitted this happened
and it wasn't that much of a struggle
the defense didn't put up
that much of a fight but they did a
little and on to the penalty phase now
terry and brian appreciate the insight
here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the long crime network is everywhere and
we invite you
inside the jury box this is law and
[Music]
crime
[Music]
[Music]
you